peut-être de l'aude et en l'occupation
dure depuis huit jours il ya une agora
aujourd'hui pour s'élever contre la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
et là je me trouve avec l'un des
occupants mathieu qui est musicien
bonjour mathieu alors vous êtes venus
depuis le début voit ici oui je voulais
arriver donc une semaine jeudi dernier
mois je suis arrivé avec la première
équipe je suis musicien donc on a rentré
le matériel de musique parce que c'est
quand même une une occupation
revendicatives mais quand même joyeuse
alors ok qu'est ce qui a présidé à votre
envie de d'occuper ce théâtre bon c'est
à dire on a des problèmes dans le champ
culturel on a des revendications dans le
champ culturel donc la prolongation des
droits des intermittences qu'on a
inscrit ce qu'ils ont appelé l'année
blanche
on demande à fond pour pour travailler
pour avoir le moyen de payer des
répétitions pour financer on demande des
mesures pour les pour les primo entrants
les nouveaux entrants les femmes
les femmes enceintes et les arrêts
maladie on demande l'ouverture des lieux
et puis à tout ça évidemment s'ajoute la
réforme de l'assurance-chômage
l'annulation de la réforme d'assurance
chômage parce que c'est quand même un
point une paire centrale dans le monde
dans lequel on vit en ce moment vous
avez beaucoup de revendications pour des
droits ce qui veut dire que en ce moment
là vous nous le confirmer la profession
est sinistré et beaucoup de vos amis de
la culture sont dans des situations
économiques très difficiles
bah ouais nous nous sommes enfin on peut
plus travailler les lieux sont fermés on
en a pas fais moi j'ai pas fait beaucoup
de concerts de l'hiver quasiment aucun
en fait quoi et donc du coup ses traits
fins vollard non pas nous c'est très
très très compliqué de travailler en ce
moment les lieux sont fermés que ce soit
dans dans les salles de spectacle ou
voilà les cinémas sont fermés les bars
les restaurants sont fermés c'est des
lieux aussi où on travaille pas mal
l'événementiel est à l'arrêt
il ya tous les tous les secteurs
d'activité où on peut travailler faire
de la musique des concerts ou des
spectacles tous les talents c'est très
très compliqué pendant comment vous vous
organiser ici pour justement résister
militer pas que cette occupation soit
réussie que vous obteniez des choses est
bon
alors moi pour obtenir des choses aux
occupants des vous êtes vous savez on a
il ya maintenant environ 20 lieux qui
sont occupées donc on est il ya l'odéon
il ya ce qu'on fait ici ce qu'on a fait
ici est ce qu'on aura pulse et puis il
ya après de maintenant tous les lieux
occupés ou voilà le l'élu qui se
produisent et tout ça donc
mais ici au bon voilà c'est des espaces
ouverts on occupe ici nous centre
névralgique de l'occupation et 6 1 on a
monté le matériel de musique là derrière
on fait des concerts tous les soirs il
ya des âges et des ag ont lieu ici on
non il ya le les lieux où l'on mange
sont plutôt là où on veut y vachement à
areva respecter les gestes barrière
apporter tout ce masque et à faire
attention à tout ça quoi
et vous avez l'intention de rester
jusqu'à quand danse théâtre c'est pas
moi qu'il faut poser la question il faut
que vous alliez voir jean castex
roselyne bachelot emmanuel macron
chercher on a du mal à savoir qui décide
et qui fait quoi parce que pour tout
vous dire c'est pas très clair mais
c'est d'eux que ça dépend nous nous on a
des revendications demandant à ce
qu'elle soit satisfaite si elles sont
satisfaites de mort je pense qu'on je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord pour
entrer chez nous et puis et puis
retravaillées enfin nous c'est ce qu'on
veut